Cambridge is famous for its University
and it's River punting but it's now got
a place in the history books for
recording the highest ever temperature
in the UK 38.7 degrees in July last year
we've all felt the summers getting
warmer the winters wetter and so on but
these new statistics are further
evidence that our country and in turn
our planet is experiencing more extreme
weather 2000 to 2009 was the warmest and
wettest decade of the past century but
between 2010 to 2019 which was the
second warmest and wettest decade
weather records were also set in
traditional winter and spring months of
January February and April the last
decade had just one low temperature
record in March 2018 certainly in a
warming climate we do expect to see
certain types of extremes become more
frequent so these high temperature
records for example and that's being
borne out by the data that we're seeing
here in the UK and that's a trend that
we will expect to continue through the
21st century the so-called beast from
the east barreled through Britain as the
coldest March day ever recorded but
similar weather systems will become more
common climate change is the long term
shift in average weather patterns the
release of carbon dioxide and other
greenhouse gases caused temperatures to
rise but it's not just the UK which has
been experiencing more extreme weather
globally 2019 is expected to be the
second or third hottest year since 1850
Lisa Holland
Skyler's
let's get some expert opinion now why
don't we list Bentley the chief
executive of the Royal Meteorological
Society joins me now in the studio it's
good to have you on the program this
hour and anecdotally we've been saying
for a long time or it's hotter this
summer isn't it and the winters aren't
is as terrible as before so now you've
got evidence first-hand evidence that
the UK at least if not the planet is
getting warmer yes so the data that's
come from the Met Office has clarified
what we already knew we've had these
record-breaking temperatures not just in
2019 but also over the last decade and
we've seen eight high temperature
records being broken and only warm low
temperature records that was linked with
the beast from the east back in March of
2018 how does that compare to other
decades to have eight so we've seen more
and more of these high temperature
records being broken a greater frequency
of those and we're seeing less and less
of the low temperature records being
broken so we've seen that shift and as I
said we would expect that as we're
seeing a warming generally in our
climate so we've had about a 1 degree
Celsius warming in the UK since about
the 1850s very similar to the the the
global average temperature increase that
we've seen as well but so and here in
the UK and the figures that we've seen
from the metal of his focus on the UK
you can see that with that extra warm in
that 1 degree warming when we get
heatwave events like we had in July and
the extreme temperatures that we saw
that extra heat is put on so we in
heatwave events we see even more extreme
temperatures and the records being
broken that we saw last year in the
first week of January so it was quite
nice isn't it to look at someone eating
an ice cream yeah and of course you know
for a few days it's nice at least but
but it is serious isn't it especially
have a big metropolitan areas and it's
incredibly hard to do work and live in
that environment isn't there part of the
fact it's also bad for the environment
it has real consequences doesn't it yeah
and one degree warming doesn't sound
very much but the impacts that that has
can be quite extreme well again if you
look back to the heatwave that we had
over the summer the the the impact it
had on infrastructure for you remember
there was melting of rail tracks and the
electric cable so your infrastructure
isn't really geared up for those high
temperatures the impact it has on humans
and ecosystems and mortal
to attend to rise during that extreme
heat so it has a real negative impact on
us not just you know taking the
enjoyment with a bit of warm sunshine
and extra ice creams that we can have
it's the impact that it has the negative
impact of course the flooding is just
terrible as if anyone who's lost their
home because of funny it's not at all
kind of get anyway is getting warmer as
a trend but we had the beach nice didn't
we two or more years ago and that was a
bitingly cold winter for a long time
what happened then yeah so unusually
cold spell furs in the UK it came at the
very end of winter and into the early
spring as well so again you know
springtime you would expect you to start
warming up and it's certainly and that
was when we had our lowest temperature
record in this last decade so that
happened on the 1st of March in 2018
during that beast from the east what I
would say is if it wasn't for that
that's a reminder if you needed one Liz
yes the other extreme the other end I
guess of the extremes but if we hadn't
have had that one degree warming that
we've seen across the UK over this last
hundred fifty years or so that could
have actually been a much colder event
than we actually experienced Wow and
that has huge ramifications didn't it
for the country we talked about
infrastructure not coping with the heat
certainly nothing coped with it with
snow across the country so what is your
call to arms them what is your call to
actions for the next decade as we head
into the 2020 yes I think data like this
that's coming from the Met Office is
evidence of what's actually happened if
we look back over the last year or the
last decade we need now to think about
what what's likely to happen in the
future and what we can do about that and
2020 I think is a really key year for us
in the UK we've got cop 26 that will
take place at the end of the year in
Glasgow a real focus on climate change
in the UK a real Kolbo for individuals
businesses but especially governments to
look at how we not only in the UK but
globally can focus on mitigating against
climate change so reducing the effect
the the the the warming effect that
we're likely to get because of climate
change but also adapting to climate
change we're seeing it happening we've
seen it over the last year over the last
decade and we'll see more of that and we
need to adapt to that is the political
will there is momentum there to make
proper changes what do you think
well it's mix there's there's certainly
if you look globally there were some
countries that are trying to push
forward setting you know strong targets
and
to meet them but I think we're we're
behind the curve there's a lot of action
to be taken and cop 26 I say at the end
of the year I think can be another
refocus not just for us in the UK but
but globally as well okay we'll leave it
there Liz thank you so much Liz Bentley
the chief executive of the Royal
Meteorological Society thanks